[Music]
you're in mississippi
and everywhere you go tamales
those magical little snacks of corn
flour and meat
packed into a corn husk
tamales tamales tamales
so if you've ever wondered what
mississippi tastes like
it tastes like me
the tamale
[Music]
my journey starts almost 100 years ago
it's 1930. and mexican migrants are
trickling into mississippi
they bring along a taste of home
their version of the sandwich
me
the tamale
my great-grandfather came here from
mexico city
jumped the trains ended up in
mississippi he decided to make his
family's homemade hand-rolled hot
tamales and in 1939 opened up this place
and started selling tamales
you have to understand this is a family
thing i'm the fourth generation
these same generational people who've
been coming to the big apple in for the
last 78 years are also generational
when they eat a tamale they always have
a story my daddy used to bring me here
his daddy had the same kind of story his
daddy had the same kind of story
tamales caught on here and it became a a
staple in in the city
so there i am winning over the
mississippi natives and as i make my way
up into the delta
my location may change but little did i
know that the tradition of family
most certainly would not
just like geno and his grandfather at
the big apple inn i bring the scott
family together a family who has gone on
to be known
as the first family of tamales in
mississippi
in the early 50s my father bought the
recipe from a mexican guy
my mother and father taught me
my sisters and my niece all of us
together we're making hot tamales we
just one big hot tamale family
any business that's family oriented i
think it'll last longer
[Music]
much like the scott family
the dough family is made up of a long
line of tamale makers
dough's eat place is a landmark
restaurant that helped propel me to
become the backbone of mississippi
cuisine i've become today
[Music]
my daddy started this restaurant in 1941
with my mother we've been here 76 years
mama had a
sister that was living here and daddy
had a couple of two or three sisters
that were living here so they all came
enrolled tamales
you know a lot of people ask ask us you
know how did tamales get prevalent in
the delta uh it's been family you know
the family's been here all the time
as tamales made their way from mexican
culture to african-american communities
and on to mississippi's white population
there's one thing that remained a
constant
family
the most southern concept of all
[Music]
you could go down alleyways anywhere in
the city you're going to find wild food
i mean literally everywhere
there are things that are very tasty
very palatable
you can't possibly get fresher food
[Music]
my name is christopher nierges and i'm
the founder of the school of soft
reliance
i study the uses of plants and i teach
city people how to use them
if i lived in those you could forage
maybe for mushrooms
my whole life i've been interested in
the outdoors
it's always been my love to feel more
self-reliant so i'm happy to be able to
do that
[Music]
los angeles really is a good place to
forage
the fringes of parks
the edges of gardens the edges of farms
i'm a very fast efficient harvester
i'll take a bag and a knife
period i have a mental map i know where
there's a lot of this and i need that i
could go there
in the heart of la yeah there's little
pockets all over
people who have gardeners
as soon as the weeds come up they cut
them down that's the biggest obstacle
for me regularly collecting wild foods
the challenge is in the way we view
the so-called weed these are some of the
most nutritious plants on the face of
the earth and yes there are things that
may be different than what you're used
to eating
so we collected mustard flowers radish
flowers pods and leaves mallow fruits
and leaves yucca flowers purslane and
lambsquarter leaves
it's just what i do as part of my normal
diet
i do it because i i just like doing it
i like the idea of making something from
seemingly nothing i could make a meal
from just things that i've gone out and
collected i could make fire with sticks
to me
that's very empowering in a way even if
i never have to do it
[Music]
i'm going to do a loop on each end
what i do on my classes we're going to
take people out and we're going to
actually see the plants in the field
let's see what we have over here
i get people from all walks of life who
come to these classes
some want something that's more
nutritious
some are the survivalists some want just
a different experience
of food the foodies
i'm not in a position to solve the
world's problems but i'm in a position
to convey to individuals
new choices that they can make
so i'm happy to pass that along to
others it's an amazing feeling
[Music]
vegetables and fruits around the city
and horse-drawn carts
my grandfather's been doing it all his
life he 80 something years old now
i've been doing it all my life and it's
been around
50 maybe 100 years before me
[Music]
you're in baltimore you got markets
around but you gotta have a vehicle to
get to them it's gonna cost them to get
there cost them to get back so it's
beneficial to a lot of people for the
rappers to be on the street
y'all have a go
[Music]
every morning pull my wagon up i get all
the fruit together and design it up make
it look nice
and then i take the horse and put them
in the wagon i start on my day
you mostly call out what you got on your
wagon
when you come up and you see an elderly
person just waiting at the door for you
to come through and they give you that
little list that's a wonderful feeling
so they depend on us and we try to be
there for them
hey rabbits for life baby a rabbit's for
life
the kids they love the horse
[Music]
and i want them to be able to see that
selling drugs ain't the only way to make
money
this is what keeps me out of trouble
this is what feed my families would put
food on the table pay the bills pay the
gas
this is one of the the oldest things in
in the city that's still going right now
this is history
when i was a little kid it was nothing
for me to turn the corner see a rabbit
one right behind another sometimes
if we don't get a lot of people behind
us in the exposed arabian business it
might eventually die out
but my dream is to see it last forever
till the day i shut my eyes for good
[Music]
this story is about a secret restaurant
in madrid
oh yes tapas no we are here for chinese
treats
how did we get down here again buckle up
that's a long story
[Music]
it all started when we got a tip saying
madrid had the secret chinese restaurant
the most authentic food ever but very
hard to find let's go
there was no email no proper address all
reviews pointed to a mysterious
underground location we called the one
number available
no response oh what a shame no wait we
didn't give up that easily we got a
friend in madrid to get to the bottom of
it and she got us the right directions
good thinking i got it i got it there
are no signs so follow these tips
we got to madrid and followed the very
detailed instructions take notes people
go to plaza espana truck get to the
southeast corner check find the parking
lot entrance go down the stairs double
check oh look i started the restaurant
remember there are no signs oh yeah i
forgot go down more stairs
go through the corridor walk a bit
whoa whoa wait
i think that's it
and that's how you find cafeteria yulung
zoo better known as tisha
everyone meet you lung zoo and luffing
zoo oh mr fuji
and these two serve some of the most
genuine chinese food in spain
that looks so good
here
these delicacies are not just your
average chinese dumplings they're from
the couple's hometown xinjiang in the
surrounding province zeijang in
southeastern china it's actually where
the majority of madrid's chinese
population is from um
like really like it for a restaurant
that was this hard to find it seems like
this place never stops going
[Music]
you gotta tell us who does your
marketing
we'll take that as a maybe
ah that was totally worth the trouble
please can we start filming now i am
really hungry
nestled in between the skincare love
beauty spa and advani's pest control
school here in elmhurst queens is
indo-java a two-aisle mini-mart for all
things indonesian but
every tuesday it turns into the city's
smallest restaurant with truly authentic
indonesian food hi
welcome
you're in luck you got the best table in
the
i house see it's also the only table
[Music]
my name is david chayadi
i'm the
owner of the indo-java
we opened indoor java 10 years ago
every tuesday i cooked right here for
all the customers
we call one's lasa so it means tuesday
food stall
this little soup turned one table pop-up
restaurant isn't complete without one of
the smallest kitchens in the world our
kitchen is very tiny it's a love kitchen
because just enough for two persons
two people might be a stretch
it's half the size of a broom closet but
it doesn't stop dewy from whipping up
classic indonesian fare like gouda and
rendang i am
[Music]
just like the original
yummy
before there is none indonesian store
it's difficult to find the ingredient
from indonesia and we miss the community
if we have a store the indonesian people
will come here and then we still can
talk indonesian language
that's our our dream and then now is
happen
[Music]
i'm not a professional chef i don't have
any the education chef background so i
just learned from my mom
in the restaurant the chef always hides
in the kitchen i like to talk with the
customer when i serve the food so we can
sharing the story
they always say it next week i have to
come again
[Music]
you